[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody
good morning happy Tuesday gamespot live
we're live and Persia here max is
joining me today because we're playing
some apex legends of course and uh the
brand-new voidwalker event just went
live today we just finished downloading
it so I were a couple minutes late it's
fine yes would be like what 30 minutes
ago yeah exactly so if you guys are
playing right now the the update is
available go and check on that so yeah
we're gonna freakin play some apex guys
so obviously new events so we have new
mode which is armed and dangerous such
shoddy snipers which is pretty dope yeah
definitely it takes me back I think is
this exact same map I don't know we'll
find out in a second yeah the map is the
same okay I'm downloading HD textures
still but yeah let's see if oh snap
let's see we can invite Erik okay yeah
in his lobby but don't know if he's done
with the update or not yet we'll see
maybe we should play one game without
him yeah but in the meantime do we want
to check out the new skin oh you already
got the new skin oh yeah well rapist my
main obviously so I got to get all the
skins for her how much did the skin
costs it was eighteen hundred coins oh
so it was a little expensive
but where I said if you're a wraith man
honestly it's really nice - oh yeah I
love it it's really cool it's kind of
giving me like destiny vibes sort of or
even the halo yeah the helmet yeah
what's up - everybody in the chat crime
as always we also got alpha and Kobe and
Sawyer and God of War oh man we got a
whole bunch yes everyone tuning in
alright so let's go ahead and do this yo
play it like one game kind of get a feel
for first yeah cuz shoddy snipers
definitely takes me back you know used
to play shoddy snipers modes and handles
though man I wasn't the greatest ashati
snipers but I was more of a shoddy guy
well in Halo 3 it sniping a little bit
harder I feel like it's a little bit
easier in this game compared to Halo
it's like yeah well it depends really I
think in recent years sniping out a lot
easier because in like some of the more
recent halos when you get shot it
wouldn't knock you out of scope yeah
yeah it's like basically whoever gets
hit first yeah crime asked if you can
read all your challenges yeah fairly
fluent Japanese and this game is a lot
of katakana which is like mostly English
pronunciation so I can read like 90 to
80 percent of what's going on on screen
what it gets like the really complicated
kanji is when it gets a little bit tough
for me but there's not a lot of that in
this games is a very American game so
yeah I like it it's it's also got a
Japanese voice acting too so a little
bit of anime in there to anime apex
legends little changeup in there yeah
I'm pretty tired of the American wait
did you say wasn't in 1889 1800 yeah
okay so armed and dangerous I think we
went into this motor yeah we did as you
can see in the top right oh you actually
can't see our mini-map
because the camera actually okay that's
right in your map look at you cheat oh
man the world is your oyster here I'll
fix the camera next game you guys yeah I
wish I met Xbox accounts out have all my
emotes and stuff
oh yeah we're playing on ps4 right now
but max always plays on good ol Xbox
yeah I mean Xbox boy so one thing keep
in mind is that oh yeah so they drop
gold weapons more but you ou can only
get light armor only light armor dangle
be super I better not dawn yeah I got a
gold triple take a huge fan here's a
gold Mozambique over here all these
weapons are out of control right now
no one landed here that's also engine
yeah that's weird you see the packing
right now somebody already call dibs on
that triple yeah already here action
going on yeah I'm not sure if there's
anything changing with the map
specifically I don't know I heard there
was some like Flags dropping and stuff
like that if there is that would be dope
but aside from that that was all I heard
but if you guys haven't seen along with
this event they also dropped this really
awesome backstory video for wreath oh
yeah and I was really it's like eight
minutes long it's amazing and I
definitely won't like race to have her
own game now after watching that I was
like I will play that game it kind of
gives more perspective on her like bald
skin yeah just like yeah like people are
wondering like where'd she got that
whole backstory
like why was she bald why is she wearing
this like weird like what's not a onesie
what's it called the when you're wrapped
up like an insane asylum
oh yeah and like the straitjacket yeah
straightjacket thing yeah sounds pretty
cool
anything we gotta make move so now you
guys you know I've been living down here
now that there's kind of less things to
worry about in terms of looting I'm
gonna feel like I focus more on yeah
I've just noticed that since we're just
using shoddy snipers they're both fairly
like ammo light weapons so a lot of room
in your inventory for a lot of other
goodies I try to pack up on grenades
actually I'm taking the jump Tower then
when we land I will throw a zipline I've
been using Pathfinder instead of
lifeline lately oh yeah because I've
been watching all of you like pro
controller players yeah Pathfinder's
amazing is it's a really it's a really
complicated grapple actually like it's
fairly simple to use but it's like so
many like niche techniques that you can
do with it
you're meeting a John okay someone's got
a shot on me pretty sure
oh I forgot so somebody's shooting us
from behind though there's gonna run you
want to chase us
yeah please shoot down this area Oh
spy on that area they might be coming in
behind it's hard to read chat and 100k
I'm still trying you guys that's why you
guys aren't looking at my feet because
you don't want to see this it's not
pretty
we could probably switch back and forth
actually but the only problem is that
audio won't sync up on your side right
yeah I don't have to do all kinds of
stuff but it's fine this is why you're
here max I'll try my best
man I have this gold piece keeper and I
haven't seen a single soul yeah it's
been really quiet I'm not liking this
yeah Norka the skin the new race skin
that's from the little movie they made
for race back story for sure for sure
oh we are
just go over here maybe something good
this way those guys go into the caves
whoo yeah modern warfare and Gears five
like it's such a good time to be playing
shooter shooter it's like it's good
because all of these like classic MO oh
I saw something gold no it was a light
ammo but I also need to get the heck out
of here yeah Oh actually I have a zip
[Music]
but yeah god war says man that gears
five newest trailers freaking epic oh
man how new did I miss it yeah I'm like
I might not have seen that one yet
yeah I'm behind the times I wanna see
you there's just been so many like games
coming out it's really hard to like keep
track all of them yeah this wrong it is
gonna be crazy there's gonna be a lot of
good releases this month there was like
three games released on the 30th alone
yeah which is awesome keep bringing the
games well why are you yeah it's been
kind of a low for a while old arrow over
here is it just him by himself no he
went down
so there's definitely teammates yep
they're over there they're in the storm
oh yeah watch out watch out there's like
over here in the photo roll oh oh
I don't know if they can see me you know
what I'll walk away from these oh wait
I dropped my box right next to you I was
actually perfectly oh man oh I kind of
like that they've updated like how much
damage you do to people yeah they did
that like a couple weeks ago I think I'm
a fan of that oh he had a mastiff well
apex make a solo ranked mode or no I
know they have the solo mode like
limited time for the last events the
iron crown oven oh snap we got the
squash yeah thank God
Eric's back in or doing anything oh yeah
crime said to read your challenges he
wanted to see how they sounded on the
spot Sanju Chi I don't know the kanji
but I do so he got 230 headshots with
somebody with someone's uh looks like
get a win below that might be you still
a beast bro it's true that's true
lemon daily challenge seven times clear
clear 70 a challenge or something like
that you know typical challenge things
yeah something along those lines I
usually like if they say a character I
can like figure it out from there
again it's like 80% understanding of
language Japanese looks like it's a good
for like just recapping on my Japanese I
haven't used in a long time so crime
says he wants to visit Japan one day
same yeah me too yeah
if you're a gamer anime guy you gotta go
at least once we got Bob Jones and
mystical Nisha back in the chat welcome
back hope you guys had a nice long
enjoyable Labor Day weekend oh it's not
a for Xbox yet though oh no I mean
around 10:30 is when they became
available for ps4 so if it's not out
yeah it should be soon yeah oh he picked
the Pathfinder first that you got oh
oops it's a bang yes okay she is still
good you're a fan of bingler I started
using a hot fire in Bangalore a little
more recently her like movement oh yeah
I was a life blaming before but I also
couldn't get away yeah so I was like you
know let me try some of these other
other characters oh my goodness
hurricane weekend oh my gosh please stay
safe everybody it's been terrifying
watching all the coverage and seeing how
you know the trajectory of their
hurricanes changes so much we're still
just coming from huh which direction is
it coming from it's coming from like
it's like going from like the bottom of
Florida like it just hit the Bahamas
super oh man I know it's crazy
Oh y'all watch out oh okay longbow I can
work with this yeah
what there's nothing oh man oh man we
get to the same houses I know I was like
of course I would not find a weapon and
oh I tried to use a grapple and I saw
some smoke that's the part I know yeah
switching heroes I literally can't find
the gun which is where's uh where's taya
over there just eliminating the whole
squad by himself I think it's just a
solo doing teh things yeah when it comes
to this game he's the heart carry I'm a
50/50 carry like sometimes I'll pop off
and other times I'm just trash there's a
reason why I was like lying man
oh I tried to use my grappling man
there's no armor anywhere it's really
limited or yeah even though it's only my
armor it makes a difference yeah we're
playing on ps4 right now and not playing
on PC but I've actually been really
enjoying watching these twitch rivals
good it's been pretty fun to watch like
you know obviously they incorporate
personalities and sup to so it's not
100% like competition B's but they do
have a ton of pros and a ton of really
good players and they had like t-squared
and snipe down in there like they
weren't teaming together but they were
playing and both of em are using
controller also well they're playing
controller yeah Wow against PC players
like it's really cool interesting I
think like the first round actually he
scrapes team won the first round
that's cool I definitely see somebody
about
[Music]
oh this is a completely new area yeah
there's a definite area where did that
lifeline though the lifelines here
somebody's aiming at me I don't know if
I'm where though I'm looking I'm
sticking near my portal just in case
they shoot what is there oh god I see
how am I the kill leader oh I killed the
kill leader
I was like no way imma go later everyone
go why is there no body armor anywhere I
know this is she had the newest lifeline
skin well not the new new line is a heel
I found this I'm watching that area
though that lifeline is still alive as
far as I know this is not good I've like
a pixel of hell can't find the new
trailer you talking about the gear Islam
or oh man this is trying to see with her
AB okay I need to like follow you guys
anywhere stay with ya okay we need to go
Libra kitty says I like using the
three-time scope for the longbow men I
feel like every time I have something
like bigger than a one time scope I
don't want it do you guys need meds cuz
I got mad packs desperately I was hoping
to find one in one of these creeps all
right I mean I don't have any left after
but oh you know what oh man okay I just
use mine cuz he needed one do
we're solo thank you oh what a low-key
love that they added a year welcome yeah
thank you I'm wondering when they did
that recording because they must have
had to like have the actors rerecord
those also this is really weird cuz like
your names are in English birth the UI's
and Japanese that's usually not the case
Oh interesting
yeah I want to see what my name looks
like writing in Japanese and also like
it's an English vo - it's usually
supposed to be in Japanese I'm not sure
what's going on right now
all right here oh he's running up
towards me oh wait oh man oh man I am in
desperate this great meals heck are
these guys one was shooting me from
inside this bunker down here Oh
what's OD what he was a headshot scary
oh well you're on your own personal I
know this guy I heard him reading
towards my left nightly oh isn't that
good
shoddy snipers rough when you only got
like light shields
I'm not a fan because I'm almost always
running everything but shoddy snipers in
this case I'm writing always SMG or
assault rifle all the time actually
really like longbow and as of late I've
been using the Peacekeeper more just
because I've been enlightened by the
cheapness that is the Peacekeeper
peacekeeper yes it's like either really
great or like really bad like three
damage I'm like what zero damage or like
150 it's like yes there's only white
armor in this mode Erik I feel like the
health packs are limited also because I
was running around looking at everything
you know I kind of hate that but I kind
of like that too because like the the
caustic we were shooting out like he
have like no armor so it's nicer to be
in those situations like okay they don't
have that much armor it's really easy to
kill them but also kind of goes the same
for us cuz we had like 55 health oh oops
I accidentally picked Bangalore again I
always get bodied by this character
select stage Oh actually you know what
Wi-Fi smart in this mode cuz we had like
barely any heels or octane or octane
yeah
human Slayer says I said loot was gonna
be hard to come by and well that is that
is true so far it's a lot of shotguns
and snipers in Nam
honestly I can only imagine how in seen
this motives like on PC Oh God you know
there's a pathfinder on top of some sort
of mountain sniping you
yeah ask me a lot of aiming guys on on
PC for sure especially oh it's just a
new area this is new area you see that
portal right there sticking up next to
ya know that's where we were at that's
we were fighting at the Oh gotcha gotcha
yeah I just realized that portal thing
was there yeah it's really cool-looking
you can go in it although that's we
should try to land in it next time see
if it takes us in jump into the portal
yeah that'd be cool it's gotta take us
something all right
everybody wants to go yeah okay well
this is gonna be hot oh my god there's
so many people there's so many people
and I know what I'm running I'm just
gonna straight over I'm gonna say I
still enough again but I punched
somebody one good time I'm going over
here sorry I don't know I don't know
I've literally amazing sorry today if
you're if you're not listening I'm
fighting but I'll come back after I get
a weapon just I have nothing okay you're
on your own dude I told you I don't have
literally jack [ __ ] we'll come back for
your banner the second I get a gun we're
in there oh my god like the worst
situation that was hell I have a
backpack but I have nothing to put in it
[Music]
all right
hopefully I can get like some old
exactly hasn't been yet so yeah sure
I'll take a choke for the weapons I
don't have
this is oh my god this loot is so bad oh
god people think here too you know I got
eight bullets right all their soul in
there okay I did I'm just executing
inside on after al oh I'm dying
I'll bring you the meds I didn't want to
waste me ammo but someone's over there
shooting at me okay alright Mozambique
Ana Eva we are we we should go grab tea
yeah yeah I'm back I have a gun now so
I'll drop some meds behind me somebody
over here there's people everywhere I
know they're okay we're coming back
oh he crawled underneath you there so
we'll find you
actually I don't think he has done
either Oh
I'm using all my ammo I only have five
bullets
wait I have to move banners way down
there I don't know I don't know how to
get down there oh Jesus hey what did you
do
where did you go it's like okay I
literally can't
Oh No everybody okay that's our van Eyck
okay do a good big portal there Oh God
oh you went into the portal oh no I
didn't well I think Eric went into the
portal okay I'm gonna check that out
actually
yeah taste I take the portal
Monica oh geez oh it's a launchpad oh
that's so sick okay that's pretty damn
cool in Atlanta
Yeow Oh what the heck oh that sucks no
sick definitely a behind you yeah so
much gab thinkin up the plate
Wow really yep there might be another
way out of here yeah they're right oh my
dead [ __ ] yeah hey that was a terrible
move I'm sorry yeah
crime is right like other everyone else
is in the same situation as us so it
shouldn't be as scared like I only have
five bullets that guy probably doesn't
have any ammo either there were so many
people there which was so hilarious I
think the move is to move from the
outside in so we should land somewhere
around that area grab some weapons and
then run in and mop up after that's the
movie because if we do exactly what we
did last time we're gonna die are we
gonna play Gears 5 100% honestly after
gears 3 like I didn't really play that
much so I didn't play much before at all
but I'm pretty excited to check out 5
I've been hearing nothing but good
things about it yeah I don't play gear
since 2 in a while
gears is probably one of the only games
I've played like shooter games that I've
played and was actually like oh yeah I
do want to check out the campaign yeah
and actually play through the campaign I
think the first one really hit me I
don't know there's so many iterations
actually I'm gonna get never actually
played the new ones after but I heard
they just didn't live up to the first
one
is that true I have fun with one three
three campaign wise Elise yeah campaign
lame gameplay wise you pretty much stay
the same he's pretty much the same like
there were a few things here and there
that were different things they tried to
fix yeah
all right so I'm gonna jump master we're
gonna land somewhere outside of it and
move our way in so we can either go to
the tower or go to like this area I'm
done with that okay cool
a little closer howdy Ben what is it
it's uh Ben
oh yeah I wanted to try to land in it I
forgot the next time the the little
dropship is going that direction yeah I
think we'll try to veer off and go
different directions - sorry Mozambique
say not cool I don't know if we should
let's just go this way let's go this way
wait that all together bound to be good
yeah well once once I get some guns
let's be prepared this time man this
really limited ammo has really limited
weapons never even noticed this much
okay
this area has a few guns there's a
longbow
but I do need some
story of our lives
oh he actually cut down on the ammo
stacks don't even notice that oh really
yeah oh I see I just opened my inventory
to check out 14 heavy ammo that's that's
pretty small like they're encouraging
like more rush down Golu off that dead
body style yeah all right well we're
going this way anyways I guess yeah I
wonder if there's any other parts of the
map that changed that's an obvious one
out there the big portal to quiet over
here yeah I don't like it by the time
everyone gets out of wreathes new area
it's like only gonna be five squads left
yeah at least like half a people are
going there every single times it's a
new area
chat what did you guys do on Labor Day
weekend you guys had to have done
something exciting
sniper stuck here
Wow the armor is just insanely difficult
to find all right let's bow nor all the
loot with that yeah I didn't get a gold
gun this way this time though
unfortunately yeah yeah we have fun to
gold guns last time we dropped another
camp oh yeah I feel like we dropped
somewhere like really random series yeah
that wasn't even that good
ay-ay-ay I need you to calm down buddy
all right there's literally no armor
none of us have armor I know it's so
cold out here
oh man they're coming towards you all
right where are these guys can you think
there's one inside the building one is
armored yeah he's right below yeah all
right cool
well they don't have any armor here
we're so spoiled I know the only
explanation
all right well I need some freakin hell
yeah but to say you have frickin thank
you all right so nine squads left no a
fan I could I could roll with this piece
with the longbow
and now every time I've gotten the armor
before I feel like I got really lucky
yeah right
don't take honor for granted now Oh over
there here which direction oh it is over
there
Oh Mike saison you playing lifeline in
this mode yeah I'd probably recommend
like lifeline or octene people can heal
themselves
yeah there's throw a little higher I
feel like what yeah well be sure flank
around let's explore this way
are you still firing I'm just
distracting them through you guys
so that they don't think we laugh oh
[ __ ]
well I got the shield
oh where is he he's right running too
you know Eric's got me no worries
yeah when I first started playing apex I
like did not use the abilities as much
as I should have you there but now I'm
like I was like way we're all in here
to recharge machines that's not right
let you guys have some more help god
what the heck well you got a shield
that's good yeah one shield out all of
us just going back to see what's going
on out here that guy died immediately
right so he's our solo guy no he went
down yeah okay I kind of wanted to fend
here then right I have people trying to
pick up his banner yep or they're all
randoms and they don't care about him
that's entirely possible too that
happens to me all the time guys are
still over here
[Music]
this is too quiet I don't like this
crime said see as soon as you started
thinking they have the same shitty
shields you do then it's all easier it's
true it's true I was like we all suck
right now we're good yeah we can camp up
there for a while pick up the gold
long-bone there's a gold longboat it was
I mean I'm a two times longbow kind of
guy something about the two times tight
I just love I probably should've gotten
a better scope but I was just so adamant
about not using it we're in a pretty
good position with the ring right now
election we are actually but I hear
gunfire
kind of wish we had
I saw a gun firing coming from that
direction are you sure I don't see
anybody over there no no I kind of want
a bigger scope I know and I was like man
missed opportunity we're inside yeah we
got a good ring positioning right now
house you know it I kinda wanna go for
that lewd pro instinct says when I use
the Peacekeeper it was like a damage
since the netcode is off on the scheme I
feel like this is probably some of the
better but yeah I want that I'm on my
way everybody like ran over there yeah I
mean we got a portal so might as well
I'll take that I'm really wondering
where they are though I don't like this
I know
all right one leg up get too scared to
stay down there too long I have the
advantage of might as well keep it I
also got a better scope so now I feel
feel pretty good I mean this is actually
really good oh the last two squads are
fighting somewhere I don't know yeah
that is true did you hear that where
that was coming from it sounded like
that same area I was pinging earlier but
I don't watch that spot well we have
rings so waiting nearby know we might
we'll just go for the dub I don't want
to over extend too much is dub for the
stream yeah with my whole like 90 damage
I've done this entire game let's go yeah
this is exactly what I'm talking about
I'm like 50/50 I'm either complete
trashed or I'm like popping off or at
least 1k damage and five kills right now
there's so many little movement things
on the map in general that I'm always
like I see Oh Sam
there's two and one run left but two
stayed in the back
oh my goodness me down oh no me okay got
a shield oh this is not good yeah this
is scary you don't watch this oh nice
the other squad showed up this is gonna
make you kind of a blessing and a curse
being on top of there we were I know
thanks from both sides
I saw them run by I only landed like one
shot sort of like hardcore mode because
there's such limited health and armor oh
oh what happened oh okay I just got my
HD textures installed
yeah we did we did that he'll talk
didn't have as much coverage as I
thought it did yeah I feel like that was
really bad positioning just because they
were positioned perfectly to pinch both
of them and they both had pathfinders
they could both come up - yeah
Pathfinder's the wave
an operator on your team yeah ah yes
apex things okay area okay I see you an
invite okay you might be able to just
join us through them all right cool
all right so we got top three yes and
bad we were rolling for a while it's the
end there is kind of rough I'm trying to
decide like which sniper is for me the
question
I still think longbow yeah I think it's
the best one trip will take has been a
love-hate relationship with it also
depends on the scope to because I think
the scope that I got with her with the
gold triple take earlier was just way
too big Azure four times of 10 this is
armed and dangerous which is shoddy
snipers only limited ammo limited loot
only white armor and helmets it's pretty
intense
very limited stuff very limited anything
I think I've seen more like shotguns us
my person to have like healing items and
grenades
great like weapons are fairly readily
available every time I see a medkit now
I'm for it yeah I had a bunch of
syringes
it was very no healing practically image
like it's not worth the time I'm
spending to the heal
not that much armed but very dangerous
going to explore over their holiday
misadventure hello Pathfinder I know
[Music]
good ol bastion there's like a robot guy
in every game now
they had true the one in cod it's like
Oh something yeah yeah I know you're
talking about there's like evolution of
robot shuffle longbow okay you guys see
anybody no but I hear people in school
Tom
ooh gold backpack okay
now you make some use of it those that
are just dying they'll be nice and none
of us have armor cod armor armor is like
the new commodity now all right thanks
do we want to take a peek over in school
time why not
nah I've oh no it's good
watch out for the new kill leader friend
let's go this way
I kind of want to stay on high ground
here gonna lock down that area
ooh Pro instinct so sport night has the
best night code in the Battle Royale
genre you know I don't play that game I
wish I put yeah like I wish I played it
yeah
because good netcode it's very defiance
they have so much money back and I'm not
really surprised that they do Oh someone
just got reviled over here hostile over
there lynnie up let me up please okay
I am your landing those shots but we
also have another team here and yeah I
knew it there's three teams here one
minute brings that far I'm wondering if
I should go for this
oh we're behind this gun oh man just
note there's two on this side there's
enemies over here - yeah whoa boy was
like giving me anxiety from last game
yeah getting pinched lots of people in
school town still I feel like when she
head towards ring maybe we should look
there
someone's shooting at me I heard it this
direction though
no I've seen she drop down she dropped
down cuz I can't hit my shots
I feel like long-distance shooting in
this game is just it's hard yeah I just
dropped a week in here it's really bad
I hear zipline I'm crazy where these
guys went and I really don't want to
like chase after them and get 58
she's so low there though you can get it
there he's my
misuse me it's always running there's
another one up there
you know oh I'm bad no we shopping down
to you alright did you revive him call
you I'm reviving he almost didn't go
there above a thing you're up here with
us
nice there's one more okay I got one
wait oh gosh all right we're good Wow
this this optics on this freakin longbow
is insane I just picked up the gold once
and I know what you're talking about
earlier Yeah right it's like too much
and
oh no oh no that's not good at all
oh shoot okay Jacobi is asking why my
game is in Japanese huh just for fun
kind of get tired of just the just the
American
although it's really weird because
usually the audio changes - and hasn't
oh my gosh Jana's snipe and like Eric
keeps like inching in front of my screen
and I'll move left a little bit man you
know if I was actually good with sniper
I could kill everybody why is this so
hard
trying to like catches drapes oh my god
that should hit up oh man I can see the
fall-off damage so much better I mean
the fall-off like the way the bullet
projects so much better in this scope
which is actually kind of cool because
that was one thing that I felt like I
didn't know that well like how the you
know trajectory and stuff with some of
these guns work yeah that felt like the
you know the trip will take and stuff
those just go and go and go we need to
get to ring though we should be pinned
around yeah I feel like we should beat
the nerve yeah I think it's super nice
that we don't have to deal with like
purple armor right now I can't find any
oh no tell you guys
we might get pinched again yeah I'm not
gonna chase after them I'm listening to
Oh No
let's try to stay up yeah this is rough
there's two people down okay they just
killed the squad and whoever was in
battle over there I don't know where to
rotate to and I don't have the scope to
like try to out snipe him either
no that's ours oh they just respawned
somebody dang it I have no idea where
they this other squad is I had theirs
they're somewhere in this direction got
one oh nice looting oh my god us so much
ammo why am i doing this right now all
right right here okay I got her nice
she had a shield too if we can get over
there I feel like there's like people
right behind that cliff I'm feeling - oh
that's my good name where
oh really
I hit him free like a good 50 I'm
actually trashed missed all my g7 shots
hit myself with a grenade
wait was rich it's not here - oh yeah
there's a creeper in here oh there's
only one bullet oh no all right forget
it I need you all right we need to go
let's go this way
sorry guys I'm like sometimes on point
sometimes just completely trash so don't
mind me I'm solo but I want to be in the
ring where I heal yeah come up here
first
you need a meds syringe here I think
yeah I think I have a lot Oh Oh over
there over there two shields broken
oh my gosh oh nice
Eric downed one nice oh my god down in
just top off are these guys oh this is
both the squad that you shooting oh yeah
one minute rings pretty close
we like possibly have a good position
here how much of this little edge is in
the arena man I don't know where they
went but they definitely are like
they're fighting over there yeah they're
petting each other I feel like we should
brush but are you Pathfinder yeah let's
sit let's go over this ledge I it's on
the respawn so let's win all right just
one more squad now so okay can you zip
over to here it's responding okay
Oh Eric's rushing crap okay ah
oh no oh they're up there still Shh
same spot dude it's fine oh I the like
how many shield cells I could use a
Phoenix now it's not worth it highs are
open though just get the extra 50 health
oh yeah I probably shouldn't have
shouldn't have chased them yeah I don't
know our area was about to not be in the
high ground anymore anyway I think we
had a little lip up there on the top and
I think if we zipped up to the right we
had that zip line I think we could have
pushed up upon them it's okay though
yeah house close that was close I mean I
can change the Japanese if you guys want
they're fine
there I mean it takes me two second
looking this is Max's ps4 okay we can't
just have an NGO changing his stuff up
maybe I am a weeb right baby embraces it
okay
do you prefer soul or squad uh that's
hard you know I didn't play that many
solos there's definitely like good parts
and bad parts of both
I definitely like just not worrying
about dumb teammates being on solos I
think being on a squad with people that
you know and like they're good with you
definitely squads over solos but if
you're just gonna play squads without
those people just play with trash
randoms then definitely I'll take solos
any day over there so that's like my
tearless is like squads with friends
solos then squads with idiots hey you
know what idiots are talking about
you've definitely run into those be
wrong
this is your champion who's the champion
alright we're coming for you hello
cousin Earl yes it is me ha ha did we
want to change the position of the
camera or oh that's fine
yeah no one scared much since we got a
Thunderdome I guess on our way here it's
definitely a sniper area I can read
about 80% you guys already know what it
says all right that's a part of it too
it's like between already knowing some
of the stuff in like the katakana like
just reading back phonetically saying is
you're fine
oh there are some people with us I know
I'm not playing a fighting game wait I
think we dropped in normal mode oh shoot
did we oh I definitely picked up a p20
in 20 yeah same here
okay well it doesn't matter what I feel
like I don't know where the heck they
are
you couldn't hit me because I'll be
crouching oh we got more people ahead of
us another squad yeah let's see if we
have time for this we're not gonna die
no response I'm out oh I'm gonna go out
this guy watch for them ready go
somewhere up here yeah where'd it go we
bust it oh he's right here right here
right here
oh there's two people over there oh I
don't know enough ammo for this fight
okay let's I mean we should just
probably just try to get the kill
because be able to go back to you have
you gotta fight this out
I got all types of people are I don't
have the animal for this
[Music]
can we just die already yeah sorry is
one we tried to go ham we survived of
course yeah right
we don't want to live all right we Oh
what where no I ran out of light ammo
all right that's my peacekeeper
experience right down the middle and
zero damn it's not even like a seven
damage one pellet shot like nothing when
that Pathfinder was chasing me it was
like Point Blank to his face to do like
a hundred me I was like that's why is
the peacekeeper I'm not the party leader
so I can't change this I see I think
when you liked out maybe it back to man
all right here we go back to the shoddy
snipers you know we kind of went off a
little bit there
she's totally vine just katakana use
hiragana katakana hiragana our two
separate things there's max are you
better than Erica apex asks Chris L it
depends on the day seriously it's like
literally the flavor of the day
sometimes I'm Way better than him and
other times I'm just complete trash
what about you Eric are you better than
max I'm sure he has something to say
about that he's typing he's typing right
now as we speak
Oh Eric he admitted defeat I said the
switch reactions are bad now you know
I'm I'm the same they're excited to
lower my sensitivity because my twitch
reactions were overshooting everything
what sensitivity are you playing on now
I'm back to three green yes I actually
moved up to three I was on to time
that's good for sniping though sure well
you wouldn't be able to tell about how
should we land in the portal I don't
think so I'm gonna try it all right I'm
going here okay let's say I kind of want
to go in that direction we can make our
way over there yeah mobile gamers aren't
real gamers wha come on man don't be
like that we're all we're all up the
same cloth okay plus some of these
mobile games are actually like really
good wow I just think of a double
longbow fancy brave XPS fan for a while
[Music]
sick well I'm down to g77 gonna kill you
I hate the g7 in this game type it's
amazing oh yeah those are things like
that's all right first blood I'm just
always like this gun sucks
all right where are we going let's uh no
we can't go that way because out of the
ring now so I'm definitely not better
than max crimes so uh somebody's your
you go super saiyan for a little bit oh
it's a shield pecker crap I don't know
where it is now the ping wore out it was
somewhere in there all right
enemies have been here us we were there
I'll go back your favorite thing
backtracking if anything also you can
confirm that I'm also the worst looter
ever when are we doing the void thing we
are currently doing the void thing
actually yeah so this is a void Walker
mode it's basically the same things up
to one area is completely changed Lutz
really weird it's only shotguns and
snipers very very hard to find white
armor and very limited health and ammo
that's the thing about this mode to like
you'll see people and you're like do I
shoot you I want to giveaway where I am
right now we're going for a might as
well
someone berries
it's obvious we want to go that way
oh really nuke yo leader assembly which
older man you know what let's go Yolo
unless you respawn shield sells though
they're very hard to find holy those bad
boys are rare I'm not seeing anybody
okay we're in the ring
already inside you know I was thinking
high ground you know high ground high
ground probably the best now I'm
wondering if like being in the caves
might be a better idea
I spent a good fight but you don't get
like you know snipe from behind like
some third party or something yeah I
mean shotguns become powerful in here I
would much rather go for a shoddy battle
in a sniper battle yeah at least in this
game I don't know I feel likes my
thing's crazy just like it in the caves
use Watson Yeah right I'll be great
cover up all the instances if the ring
is on your side yeah we're gonna go in
the portal but it's out of the ring it's
like right here yeah I don't want to go
out there to just run back after it got
there it's fine we'll get an optimal
drop ship that'll take us there I don't
know what's right direction to go I feel
like we should hold here wait for people
to struggle in from the rain here's some
shots Southwest's how long does the
event last it is like two weeks I think
I was 2 weeks ok yeah super limited run
it's interesting I mean I think I might
enjoy this more if there was like
assault rifles in essence I do live like
regular yeah well he's like if there's
only smg's an assault rifles that I mean
for like limited ammo limited armor I
kind of like this actually
it's like hardcore mode basically like I
know it defeats the purpose but I
wouldn't mind playing this but a regular
mode like not Battle Royale like forum
yeah oh man like a team about yeah team
deathmatch might be getting to like
overwatch territory at that point but
yeah there's a zip line here it's a good
high ground hell yeah oh god they're
right here oh my god oh yeah make it
yeah I need to kill up first okay
oh no no come closer to way from the
door oh man that was a that was a moment
that was terrifying oh there's someone
here as well crap Oh
the stink the stink got me right here
what I almost have been a precision
choke god you guys from a hecka far away
no I didn't have much house yeah the
syringes man Eric also in the chat with
the Peacekeeper was he's like the
Peacekeeper hits me for like 90 I hit
him for 40 balls yeah yeah I'm not like
that I'm not a peacekeeper fan not
reliable I hate it
oh god syringes are so annoying you
spent all that time getting a sliver of
health and then then just take it away
yeah and like a shot all right I'm not
picking up surgeries anywhere I'm only
picking up med kits if they come about
yeah they're even harder to find
oh I don't even own Acton or else I
would just use him actually um do you
have luck in the stream we have eight
minutes oh seven minutes we have plenty
of time for one more again
I don't even notice that she has a new
intro with that skin or maybe she has a
new intro all together
oh yeah cuz I remember she usually like
teleports and then she's like you know
like flies towards the screen but she
rolled in with a gun up this time I was
kind of cool well it is her event as
they're all true I still really liked
her little backstory video leave just
release ya guys haven't seen it you
should check it out it's eight minutes
long when I started it I didn't look to
see how long the video was but as I was
watching it I was like this is awesome
and it's really long oh yeah back to the
hot zone
everybody's going look at all these
people
flying I guess he wants to go spicy
since we don't have that much time left
go in the hydro dam and said we'll make
our way over there yeah it's probably
better this way man literally everyone
went over there yeah that's why we're
gonna clean up afterwards all right a
double Mozambique hey I got a shield
nice it's so excited when I find it
shield in this mode next rings far less
first blood should have seen that coming
Mozambique to my orangey this is not
that great to begin with yeah yeah I'll
watch like streamers play this game and
they'll like run up to a supply create
and get a gold shield now like what yeah
I never get that it's about to go triple
Mozambique they're really three
mozambique's we should go towards the
much more calling uh should we go
towards the area it's
probably a no-kill leader hopefully I'll
find a longbow
yeah there's pendants kind of garbage
weapons so far thanks I'm not seeing
them if the flying time oh boy alrighty
do you hear anybody I heard those Wraith
but was that you that was I think is me
okay like I heard the ability zip oh no
that was the house not me
I hear feet now actually that may have
been Erik
25 seconds rings close these guys they
booked it yeah they must have au Rhum
there
I got a Mozambique in a peacekeeper
let's go we'll be fine oh there there
definitely zip right here please this
guy's so low I does not have his ah
rings coming i was mega lost where'd he
go he's crawling around somewhere down
here
hey what I'm just trying to get this
freaking long I need a headband others
some in that box I think all right I
really hope I don't get shot no please
don't shoot me okay taking is it I see
it
[Applause]
hmm I'm not liking this I don't hear him
oh no did I get glitch okay I didn't
thank God
damn that sucks I'm going to run all the
way there I hate when there's like a
tiny hole oh how come he can hit me
through that and I can't hit him through
that silly or the app there any case
also right here all right man I'm just
running for so long and I can't catch up
to anybody here there's one inside of
this building I think you know I'm just
rushing I can't catch up to these guys
oh yeah he bounced where I think they
ran out
well that was rough just a whole bunch
of running towards it I don't find any
fights I know I don't even know where
that guy went actually man he's like my
shields down yeah shield cells are
strong there now
thank you sweet
I love lifeline where do we go
I know like the action we ran into just
literally disappeared yeah and of course
now they're gonna appear out of nowhere
yep the crap out of me can't leave these
shots good yeah it's really hard to do I
try
I went too far I don't know if I should
drop down I got you hello foxy Raven
yeah we're all kind of on our own what
yeah
oh there's guys over here - those who
are biting okay so in there there's also
blood hung back here somewhere we are
once again yeah I don't like this
[Music]
just let me have it kids and work people
across you still got to worry about
these guys and their Oh
oh no what we traded and I got I got you
again oh I got Superman of us have
shield so we all have a shield on and no
[Music]
[Laughter]
it really did come out of nowhere
jump-scare if I've ever seen one
Wow that was like porno rags what the
head god that was the death with like 40
minutes and it's not a stalk should have
definitely had my heart is racing
that was something else
oh man do we have time for a respawn I
know
it's barely inside the right
definitely watch like in the
skullenbones area
you all right yes so we got four three
other squads for scouts left now oh and
another nice booty
I don't have the sniper for this where
are they shooting for him so there was a
living here but there's also people
behind this we need to go towards the
ring that darn ring no I can make this
dumb I believe in us
Oh goodbye friends
did you fall I did this is this is how I
died lessons it's okay I'll meet you
guys on the other side no like in this
anybody is definitely a squatter in that
direction that spot over there we can do
this I really want them to fight each
other I don't really know right you guys
do your thing I need health um I got
some in Gia
Thanks Healing up eyes are open though
oh yeah it's all that it's all that
portal over there no ammo can you uh how
much do you like a stack of heavy Oh
there's people over there where are you
at got you BAM
I need heavy ammo Thanks
make it count yeah I know right I really
want them to shoot each other oh you're
taking a jump tower I know he jumped
down here jump down he's just trying to
feel like they're not gonna run into
each other I feel like we're in the
middle again I feel like that too
so one squads over there but where's the
other squad is what I'm wondering I hope
they don't come from the other side of
this of the spine yeah are they shooting
at us no no okay yeah they're definitely
over there oh yeah we should rush in now
let's go this way I'm throwing is it
shoot new cheerleader watch for them
trying to pick a fight moving here yep
she's up here
all right so he's clearly over there
somewhere she's down by a jump our okay
hitter once inside yeah we're all go
yeah buddy I definitely did zero
carrying all right it's all about the
pressure I was just a human word
I was like now that was a perfect timing
oh my god anything oh all right that was
scary we did it though let's go
finally yes for the last one of the
stream the second it's not bad either
yeah well thank you guys so much for
tuning in the voidwalker
Ethan is live it's gonna be live for the
next two weeks so make sure you check it
out especially you've got those you know
the accuracy yeah those shots on luck
definitely you check it out I'm sure PC
guys will be having fun right now oh
yeah I know it's probably crazy I can't
wait to like watch some twitch action
and see everybody going ham but yeah I'm
gonna be pulling in somewhere in this
also so you guys should check it out
anyhoo hope you had fun we will be back
tomorrow at 11 a.m. and
yeah have a good one you guys all right
see guys
you